you mentioned that you've shot the video
with soda baby the next morning you had
to take your kids to daycare and then
you had to be to work at the post office
at this point in time you have a
a distribution situation with a serious
distributor that you just put your new
album out
um are you you're still not working at
the post office are you yeah you still
are yeah you have to be part-time though
this this hot is right so
after i come off tour after i get done
running around i go back home and go
back to work
still to this day still to this day
there's not no [ __ ] not no [ __ ]
bro i swear
i'm baby jesus and and for people who
don't know you know my best friend in
the world is uh he's worked at the post
office for 15 years so the benefits are
off the chain you feel me
yeah
that union is off the cha you could take
a leave of athens absence for as long as
you want
see the beauty thing the beautiful thing
about the post office is they won't fire
you
that's some real [ __ ] unless you do some
foul [ __ ] unless you
steal me right but outside and there's
some [ __ ] like that and it's people that
stole mail that's still working that
[ __ ] yeah the union
[Music]
yeah my boy anytime some [ __ ] happens
like he'll cut his like hand at work or
something i gotta call my union rapper
yeah i did
man come on bro you know what's going on
how long how long do you plan on keeping
the job like like in all seriousness
like you're you don't need it you know
what i mean like i'm not saying that
it's not good you have kids right so
it's not it's a good thing to have
benefits and have some sort of security
but like
realistically for your career to kind of
take it to to take to the next step
you're gonna need that bandwidth right
yeah probably
probably when i signed to a major